this is a busy shipping Lane and at any
moment something could go wrong it only
takes one incident to literally send
this ordinance two miles up into the air
you can ask the potential to be one of
the largest non-nuclear explosions in
the history of mankind
London and satellite towns like
sheerness on the coast face a deadly
threat
the population could have a casualty
rate far higher than anything it
suffered in the Second World War
yet a one and a half kiloton blast isn't
the only thing that could devastate
London
case scenario this
this some analysts have concluded it
would race up the Thames and smash into
the center of London